we uh like many others we actually had a
very humble beginning where we started
in our apartment um especially for my
apartment on my couch
we were we were so early we were
pivoting and the global pandemic just
happened
for the first time nobody had ever done
anything in this kind of environment and
we just like got a bunch of accidental
traction there were so many questions
and i
i wanted a lot of smart people to try to
poke holes
in my idea my business plan and it gave
me exactly what i think i needed which
was a structural
way to challenge you intellectually to
poke holes
to ask those tough questions so that you
have no choice but to
formulate clear answers and articulate
them in a concise way i started my
fundraising process and i would say i
think two to three months after
graduating from the program and by the
time i was on the road pitching a lot of
people
i was already feeling very comfortable
very familiar
whether i get a yes or get a no i know
what's coming
it's moving on what to care about what
not to care about
i was um ready to
i think take a lot of the challenges
head-on knowing what's coming my way
and the program does a fantastic job of
that and we ended up raising
um a four million dollar round within
six months of completion
it was quite remarkable and beyond our
expectations
you